Hallo, merhaba.
Hallo, guten Tag.
Guten Tag.
Mein Name ist Bilal Altan, ich bin hier auf dieser Station,
die Insta-Wende Arzt tätig und ich werde mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch
durchführen. Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, gerne.
Ja, bevor wir über Ihr aktuell besprächsendes Gesprächs
sprechen, möchte ich ganz schnell Ihre persönliche Daten aufnehmen.
Wie heißen Sie?
Bitte.
Wie heißen Sie bitte?
Ich heiße Peter Müller.
Könnte Sie bitte vorne und nach Hause buchen zuabieren?
Peter, Peter ist P-E-T-E-R.
Müller, M-U, L-L-E-R.
Vielen Dank.
Wie alt sind Sie, Herr Müller?
Ich bin 60 Jahre alt.
Und wann genau sind Sie geboren?
Ich bin geboren 1943.
1963, Entschuldigung.
1. Mai 1963.
Wie viel wiegen Sie und wie groß sind Sie, Herr Müller?
Ich bin ungefähr 1.83 groß und wiege ungefähr 90 Kilo.
90 Kilo, danke schön.
Was sind Sie von Beruf?
Ich bin Bauarbeiter.
Darf ich Ihre Familienstand freien?
Ich bin verheiratet.
Und haben Sie Kinder?
Ich habe zwei Kinder.
Vielen Dank.
Herr Müller, was für Sie zu uns, wie kann ich Ihnen erzählen?
Wie Sie bestimmt schon wissen, bin ich zu Hause fast bewusstlos geworden.
Ich bin umgekippt.
Und Tattif, bitte?
Wann sind Sie gewusstlos gewesen?
Geworfen.
Ich bin gestern Abend gekommen.
Und gestern, bevor ich gekommen bin, habe ich Schmerzen auf der Brust gehabt.
Und dann bin ich bewusstlos geworden.
Gestern Abend, umgekommen, 1-mal, oder?
Sind Sie 2-mal gewusstlos geworden?
1-mal.
Gestern Abend.
Gestern Abend sind Sie gewusstlos geworden?
Ein Moment.
Bitte entweder auf die Terrasse oder auf die Lege.
Bestört.
Ich habe gestern auf dem Bau gearbeitet.
Und dann habe ich Schmerzen auf der Brust gekriegt.
Und dann bin ich umgekippt.
Okay.
Haben Sie so einige Beschwerden früher gehabt?
Eigentlich nicht.
Manchmal, manchmal.
Aber immer nur ganz kurz, ein bisschen.
Aber nicht bewusstlos geworden, das ist das 1. Mal.
Nur früher hatte Sie Brutschmerzen?
Ja, so wie so ein Stechen.
Ganz kurz.
Aber diesmal hat es länger angehalten.
Also diesmal hat es eine halbe Stunde angehalten.
Normalerweise ganz kurz immer.
Wo genau sind die Schmerzen hinter dem Brustbein?
Also es tut mir halt auch der Brusttuz weh.
Das ist so wie so ein Stechen.
Ja, Frau Herr Müller.
Strahlen die Schmerzen irgendwo in den Aufs?
Eigentlich nicht.
Das ist hier so gestern.
Als ich die Schmerzen hatte,
habe ich auch ein bisschen im Rücken gehabt.
Sie haben schon gesagt,
dass die Schmerzen eine halbe Stunde gedauert haben.
Die Schmerzen oder der Schmerz haben?
Die Schmerzen, ja,
ungefähr eine halbe Stunde gedauert haben.
Genau.
Sind die Schmerzen dauerhafter
oder manchmal gehen wieder?
Nein, ich habe immer wieder nur ganz kurz.
Gestern hat es 30 Minuten.
Jetzt geht es mir wieder gut.
Ich habe jetzt keine Schmerzen mehr.
Herr Müller, ich möchte wissen,
seit wann hatten diese Schmerzen?
Wann haben die Schmerzen überhaupt begonnen?
Kann ich gar nicht genau sagen,
aber ich habe das bestimmt schon ein Jahr lang.
Aber ich habe das jetzt vielleicht insgesamt
3-4 Mal gehabt und jetzt hat es 30 Minuten gedauert.
In einem Jahr.
Okay.
Ich habe das jetzt vielleicht insgesamt
3-4 Mal gehabt.
Und jetzt hat es 30 Minuten gedauert.
Okay, verstanden.
Sind die Schmerzen immer stechend
oder manchmal bruchend,
wie die Brust eng ist?
Gestern war es nicht nur ein Stechen,
sondern gestern war es auch eng auf der Brust.
Okay.
Herr Müller, könnten Sie bitte
die Schmerzen auf eine der Schmerzsehalle bewerten,
wo auch die Schmerzen sind?
Die Schmerzen sind sehr leichter.
Gestern war es vielleicht bei 8.
Haben Sie eine Auslöserbemeldung,
die Schmerzen verursacht?
Ja, ich habe das gestern.
Ich habe das gestern.
Um die Schmerzen verursacht?
macht nicht.
Okay.
Also, ich wollte fast die Unterhäuse auslauden.
Kann ich die감mer downtown nicht?
Haben Sie eine andere Beschwerde, Herr Müller?
Ja.
Um die Schmerzen verursacht.
Ist ihr noch schwindelig oder ist in Öbel erbrechen?
Nein, jetzt habe ich gar keine Beschwerden mehr und gestern habe ich auch nur Beschwerden auf der Brust gehabt.
Haben Sie bemerkt, dass die Schmerzen bei Belastung vermehren?
Wie meinen Sie das?
Haben Sie zum Beispiel beim Laufen vermehren sich die Schmerzen oder in Ruhe und bei Belastung sind gleich.
Haben Sie vermehrt Beschwerden bei Belastung vermehren Sie auf der Arbeit zum Beispiel?
Ja.
Okay, wenn ich arbeite, meinen Sie?
Oder wenn ich nichts mache, wenn ich in Ruhe?
Ja, also wenn ich auf der Arbeit, ist es mehr aufgetreten.
Zum Beispiel können Sie einfach Treppen steigen ohne Schmerzen.
Ja, dann habe ich keine Probleme mit.
Okay, Herr Müller, Sie haben schon gesagt, dass Sie keine Öbelkeit erbrechen haben.
Und föhnen Sie sich fieberisch oder haben Sie Husten, Herzrasen, Herzstolpern?
Haben Sie bemerkt?
Nein, Herzstolpern habe ich nicht bemerkt, Husten habe ich auch nicht.
Was haben Sie noch gesagt?
Herzrasen.
Nein, Herzrasen habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Okay, Herr Müller, leiden Sie an eine chronische Erkrankung?
Eigentlich habe ich keine Erkrankungen, ich nehme auch keine Medikamente ein.
Meinen Sie Bluthochdruck und so etwas?
Ja, ich meine Bluthochdruck oder Zuckerkrankheit, erhöhte Blutfettwerte.
Blutfettwerte weiß ich nicht, das habe ich nicht kontrollieren lassen, keine Ahnung.
Ich nehme keine Medikamente ein, eigentlich bin ich gesund.
Und Blutdruck mässig auch nicht regelmäßig.
Haben Sie auch nicht gegen diese Schmerzen eine Medikamente eingenommen?
Wegen den Beschwerden jetzt?
Ja, wegen den Beschwerden.
Ich habe das ja nur ganz kurz gehabt, ganz kurz.
Jetzt hat es so lange gedauert und dann haben wir den Notarzt gerufen und der Notarzt hat mir etwas gegeben.
Das heißt, haben Sie keine Medikamente?
Nein, musste ich nicht, ich habe das ja nur ganz wenig gehabt.
Okay, dann.
Und gestern war das so schlimm, weil ich umgefallen bin, da hat meine Frau den Notarzt gerufen und der Notarzt hat mir etwas gegeben.
Wissen Sie, was der Notarzt Ihnen gegeben hat?
Das weiß ich nicht.
Und hat das geholfen?
Ja, es hat geholfen, es ist besser geworden, die Schmerzen.
Und jetzt geht es mir wieder ganz gut, jetzt geht es mir, jetzt ist alles weg.
Erinnern Sie sich genau kurz vor Ohnmacht?
Ja, ich erinnere mich, ich hatte Schmerzen.
Sie meinen, ob ich mich an alles erinnere, bevor ich ohnmächtig geworden bin?
Ja, ich weiß genau, was passiert ist.
Okay, Herr Müller.
Und wurden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Ja, ich hatte schon mal einen Leistenbruch, was operiert worden ist, aber das ist schon 20 Jahre her.
20 Jahre, Leistenbruch.
Auf welcher Seite?
Auf der rechten Seite.
Wie ist diese Leistenbruch behandelt, operiert oder?
Ich meine, mit offenen Operationen oder mit Schlüsselloch-Operationen?
Sie meinen, ob das endoskopisch gemacht worden ist oder ob das meine offene Operation war?
Das ist offene operiert worden vor 20 Jahren?
Und jetzt haben Sie keine Beschwerden?
Nein.
Gibt es noch andere Operationen?
Ja, Herr Müller, gibt es bei Ihrer Familie eine Bekannte?
Ja, in Ihrer Familie eine bekannte, chronische Erkrankung.
In meiner Familie. Meine Mutter ist gesund, mein Vater hatte einen Herzenfakt, mein Bruder hat Stens in seinem Herzen und meine Schwester ist gesund.
Haben Sie zwei Geschwister?
Ja.
Und lebt Ihr Vater noch oder?
Ja, mein Vater lebt noch.
Er hat einen Herzenfakt gelitten.
Herzenfakt gelitten, muss man nicht sagen, er hatte einen Herzenfakt, ja er hatte einen Herzenfakt.
Ja, Mutter ist gesund.
Ja.
Danke schön.
Herr Müller, ich möchte jetzt über Ihre generelle Situation etwas fragen.
Sie haben schon gesagt, dass Sie keine Fieber haben und ich möchte wissen jetzt, ob Sie gut schlafen können?
Ja, ich kann eigentlich gut schlafen.
Können Sie einfach im Bett fachlegen?
Ja, ich kann nicht.
Ja, zum Beispiel können Sie nur mit einem Kissen schlafen.
Oder brauchen Sie manchmal zweite Kissen?
Nein, ich kann mit einem Kissen schlafen.
Okay.
Wie ist Ihre Appetit?
Mein Appetit?
Ja.
Ist eigentlich ganz gut, ich habe da keine Probleme mit.
Haben Sie in den letzten Zeiten ab oder zugenommen?
Eigentlich nicht, so wie immer.
Ich habe keine Probleme beim Wasserlassen.
Nein, funktioniert gut.
Ich habe keine Probleme beim Strullgang.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Ja.
Über die Medikamente möchte ich wiederholen.
Sie haben schon gesagt, dass Sie keine Medikamente einnehmen.
Gibt es?
Ja, ist das richtig?
Was ist richtig?
Ja, ich nehme keine Medikamente an.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Ich wollte nur standardmäßig fragen.
Herr Müller, leiden Sie unter Stress bei der Arbeit oder am Alltag?
Gibt es etwas, was Sie seelisch belastet?
Ich verstehe, eigentlich nicht.
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Es geht mir gut.
Herr Müller, über Ihre Gewohnheiten.
Ich möchte etwas über Ihre Gewohnheiten fragen.
Brauchen Sie?
Nein, ich habe auch noch nie geraucht.
Ich habe nie geraucht.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Nein, ich trinke kein Alkohol.
Ich mag kein Alkohol, ich trinke kein Alkohol.
Okay, nächste Frage ist eine Urtien-Frage.
Nehmen Sie bitte nicht persönlich.
Haben Sie Erfahrung mit Augen?
Nein.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Herr Müller, haben Sie irgendwelche Allergie?
Ich vertrage Nickel nicht so gut.
Nickel?
Nickel ist ein Element, oder?
Metall.
Nickel?
Wie reagieren Sie sich auf Nickel?
Nicht Sie sich, sondern wie reagieren Sie auf Nickel?
Wie reagieren Sie auf Nickel?
Das ist ja meistens in Metall, zum Beispiel.
Metall-Legierungen.
Ich habe dann Ausschlag an den Stellen.
Wenn zum Beispiel am Armband von meiner Uhr Metall ist mit Nickel,
dann habe ich eine Rötung.
Rötung.
Herr Müller, sind Sie vollständig geimpft gegen Corona
gegen Kindheit erkrankungen?
Gegen Kindheit erkrankungen?
Ich bin nicht geimpft.
Gegen Corona bin ich dreimal geimpft, wenn das ausreicht.
Waren Sie in den letzten Zeiten im Ausland?
Nein.
Also letztes Jahr waren wir im Urlaub.
Was meinen Sie letztes Jahr?
Vor einem Jahr waren wir in Griechenland im Urlaub.
Herr Müller, ich habe etwas vergessen,
dass ich fragen wollte.
Waren Sie im Krankenhaus wegen irgendwelchen Erkrankungen?
Ich möchte wissen, ob bei Ihnen zum Beispiel
eine Spiegelung durchgeführt werden.
Worden ist?
Ob bei Ihnen eine Spiegelung durchgeführt worden ist?
Mannspiegelung?
Darmspiegelung?
Nein, beide nicht.
Herr Müller, von meiner Seite habe ich wichtige Fragen gestellt.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Nein, ich möchte natürlich nur wissen, was ich habe
und wann ich nach Hause gehen kann.
Herr Müller, es wäre besser, wenn Sie jetzt hier bei uns bleiben.
Ich kann nicht sofort über Ihre Diagnose etwas zu sagen.
Und möchte ich zuerst Sie ausführlich körperlich untersuchen
und von Ihnen Blut abnehmen.
Ich möchte ein EKG schreiben.
Danach brauchen wir ein paar diagnostische Maßnahmen,
wie Ultraschall oder Röntgen,
wie Rost,
und dann können wir über Ihre Diagnose und Therapiemöglichkeit besprechen.
Und wann kann ich nach Hause gehen?
Nach sobald wir Ihre Ergebnisse erhalten,
können wir dann ausführlich besprechen und zusammen entscheiden.
Okay, alles klar.
Jetzt wäre es besser, wenn Sie bei uns bleiben.
Okay, fertig?
Wenn meine Kollegen Fragen haben, können Sie auch fragen.
Im Chat sehe ich keine Fragen.
Ich hatte ein paar Fragen, Herr Müller. Guten Abend.
Guten Abend.
Gestern Abend erinnern Sie sich,
wie lange hat Ihre Bewusstlosigkeit gedauert?
Ihre Bewusstlosigkeit gibt es nicht.
Wie lange waren Sie bewusstlos?
Oder wie lange hat Ihre Bewusstlosigkeit gedauert?
Okay.
Ich persönlich kann es Ihnen nicht sagen.
Ich kann Ihnen nur sagen,
dass es ungefähr zwei Minuten gedauert hat.
Erinnern Sie sich, dass die Nordarzt eine Spray gegeben hat?
Sie wollen mich fragen, ob der Not hat mir eine Spray?
Sie wollen mich fragen, ob der Not hat ein Medikament unter meine Zunge verabreicht hat?
Erinnern Sie sich, ob der Notarzt Ihnen ein Medikament unter die Zunge verabreicht hat?
Nein, hat er nicht.
Okay.
Hat Sie auch gestern Abend Schweißausbruch gehabt?
Hat Sie nicht.
Hatten Sie gestern Abend auch Schweißausbruch gehabt?
Oder hatten Sie oder haben Sie gestern Abend Schweißausbruch gehabt?
Ganz ehrlich gesagt, nein, eigentlich nicht.
Gab es damals Todesangst?
Was meinen Sie damals?
Ja, ich meine gestern Abend.
Ob ich gestern Abend Angst hatte?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Ich kann mich nur an den Schmerz erinnern.
Ich kann mich nicht erinnern, dass ich Angst hatte.
Es ging alles ganz schnell.
Ich hatte halbe Stunde, wo Sie beschweren.
Dann bin ich umgekippt und dann war ich schon im Rettungswagen.
Dann waren die Beschwerden auch schon wieder vorbei,
nachdem ich das Medikament bekommen habe.
Angst kann ich mich nicht erinnern.
Das fing sehr schnell.
Ja, ist Ihnen eine dicke Beine auch gefallen?
dicke Beine?
Nein, nein.
Okay.
Ich möchte auch wissen, ob Sie gestern eine falsche Bewegung gemacht
oder etwas schwer aufgehoben haben?
Okay.
Ich verstehe, was Sie meinen.
Ich habe genau das gemacht, wie immer.
Es ist nicht so, dass ich gestern etwas schwerer gehoben habe
als sonst.
Gestern habe ich noch nichts schweres gehoben.
Okay.
Vielen Dank.
Wollen Sie noch fragen?
Wir haben eine Frage.
Aktuell, oder nach dem Fall, hatten Sie Kraftlosigkeit
oder Kröpel oder Taupatsgefühl, so etwas?
Ich habe mich nachdem umgefallen, ob ich dann nach
diese Kraftlosigkeit kribbeln oder Empfindung stehen hatte.
Oder Sprachstörung?
Oder Sprachstörung.
Nein, das habe ich nicht.
Im Chat steht noch, ob gestern der Notarzt ein EKG geschrieben hat.
Ja, der Notarzt hat gestern ein EKG geschrieben.
Aber ich weiß nicht.
Ich glaube, er hat gesagt, das EKG war unauffällig.
Er meinte, das EKG sieht gut aus.
Er hat gestern ein EKG geschrieben, der Notarzt.
Während Sie unmächtig waren, haben Sie gehört,
was die Leute, die umgebung Ihnen sind, gesagt haben?
Während ich bewusstlos geworden bin, ob ich gehört habe,
was die Menschen in meiner Umgebung gesprochen haben.
Ganz gut.
Ja.
Ich weiß nicht.
Eigentlich würde ich sagen, ja.
Danke schön.
Ich würde Ihnen vorstellen, dass Sie für mich ein Buch sein.
Ja, gerne.
Herr Peter Müller, der
60-jährige Patient, der Bauarbeiter von Beruf,
hat sich bei uns wegen Brustschmerzen und
gestern Abend aufgetretene Unmacht vorgestellt.
Die Beschwerden haben, die Beschwerden seien,
vor einem Jahr aufgetreten.
Er hatte Brustschmerzen.
Die Beschwerden haben seit einem Jahr begonnen.
Sie haben seit einem Jahr aufgetreten.
Der Patient gab an, dass die Schmerzen in den Rücken
aufgetreten sind.
Manchmal sind die Schmerzen stechen.
Manchmal sind die Schmerzen aufgetreten.
Und die Schmerzen stechen sind, manchmal fühlt er sich wie ein Engige fühl im Brust.
Die normale Weise hat er gesagt, ist es immer wie stechend gewesen und kurz anhaltend.
Gestern Abend das erste Mal auch Beklemmung und lange angehalten, 30 Minuten.
Sonst hält das immer nur ganz kurz an, hat er gesagt.
Er hat diese Beschwerden in Form von Brust, also in Form von Stechen.
Aber gestern Abend hatte er auch das Gefühl, dass es Beklemmung war zusätzlich zum Stechen.
Und gestern Abend hat es das erste Mal auch länger angehalten.
Noch mal, wiederholen Sie das.
Okay, der Patient erwähnt, dass die Schmerzen immer stechen sind und gestern Abend ein Bruch.
Kann man beides sagen, Druckgefühl auf der Brust, der Engige Gefühl.
Gestern Abend aber auch Engige Gefühl oder Druckgefühl hatte.
Gestern Abend auch Engige Gefühl hatte.
Sehr gut.
Die Schmerzintensität wurde bei 8 von 10 auf der Schmerzskala bewertet.
Der Patient gab an, dass seine Frau einen Notarzt gerufen hat.
Und der Notarzt hat den Patienten ein Medikament gegeben, verabreicht.
Aber der Patient hat sich nicht verabreicht.
Aber der Patient hat sich nicht an den Namen des Medikamentes erinnert.
Laut seiner Frau sei er erst 2 Minuten unmächtig gewesen.
Die Fragen nach Husten, Übelkeit, Erbrechen und Gewichtverlust wurden vermeint.
An vor Erkrankungen liegt eine Inguinall-Operation vor 20 Jahren.
Herr Neutomie.
Herr Neutomie, auf der rechten Seite.
Bei der Familie des Patienten gibt es bei der Vater ein Herzinfarkt.
Seine Bruder hatte einen Stand.
Was heißt das denn? Der Bruder hat einen Stand.
Der Bruder hat eine KHK mit Stand-Implantation.
Der Vater hatte einen Herzinfarkt.
Vegetativ an einem Nese ist unauffällig.
Der Patient nehmt keine Medikamente.
Bei der Physischen Anomese leidet der Patient keinen Stress.
Der Patient hat nie geraucht und trinkt.
Der Patient hat eine Alkohol und Drogenkonsum.
Er hat eine Nickelallergie.
Er hat eine Nickelallergie, die sich mit Yukreis und Rötung auf der Haut erhält.
Der Patient ist geimpft 3-mal gegen Corona.
Er ist geimpft gegen Kindererkrankungen.
Er ist geimpft gegen Kinderkrankungen.
Ich habe nach alarmistischen Angaben von einem Verdacht auf.
Ich habe den Verdacht auf.
Er ist 60 Jahre alt.
Er ist 30 Minuten lang.